what's up everybody welcome to the next
video in our dolby institute series for
kids who can't hear good and want to do
other things good too sounds like me yep
[Music]
that's right the first thing you need to
know about mixing is that it's really
only about two things
balance
and clarity
now while this sounds simple how you get
to that end is often a game of technical
knowledge and personal intuition a lot
of its personal intuition though so
anyways here's the basics of sound
mixing long long time ago when
microphones and speakers were first
invented all audio was played through a
single speaker or you're a little record
horn and all audio recording was
captured only using one microphone this
meant that the only way to balance your
mix was to actually have the musicians
or actors move closer or further away
from the microphone that technique still
applies today it's just that we're using
software to do the same thing instead
now we're taking all those elements here
dialogue foley music effects all at
different levels and finding the best
fit for them all how do you do that i
don't know how do you do that i don't
know let's start at the beginning
levels balancing your audio the first
important factor in sound mixing is
consistency for example a character
speaking in a natural volume at the
beginning of your piece it should sound
as loud as the character speaking at the
end of the piece people pull up the
video and they adjust the volume
themselves so they're going to start
hearing somebody talk or they're going
to hear the music and they're going to
adjust the volume to where that's
comfortable so everything else needs to
be correct relative to that starting
point what is considered loud and soft
is relative and if you adjust your
volume during this process you're gonna
throw it off so simply set your
headphones and speakers to a comfortable
level at the beginning and don't adjust
them until you're done mixing the piece
one easy way to calibrate your system
without going into your levels and
dealing with numbers and facts and all
that stuff uh is basically by opening up
a few of your favorite songs that are
well mixed maybe a few videos on youtube
that are well mixed as well videos such
as
the poacher
assassin's creed 4.
nobody move
that's it don't adjust to any other
those are the only ones that are really
mixed
just listening to them adjusting your
volume is necessary just finding that
comfortable sweet spot where you can
distinguish both the uh the loud and the
soft parts and if you do that you'll
have actually calibrated your system for
mixing right there by basing it off of a
bunch of pre-existing material chances
are you have that little audio meter
that's popping up and you see your
little audio spiking in there and you
might be going why don't you just tell
me what number i should set my audio to
okay
now generally speaking like these are
just guidelines and these are guidelines
for youtube videos so it's different if
you're delivering for tv and film and
all those actual way more standardized
systems
so after doing a little bit more
research we have come to a few
definitive numbers when it comes to the
actual levels you can be minting at it's
a very flexible and ever-changing area
but when it comes to online stuff though
there are a few guidelines to use first
off you have to consider everyone's
watching this on a bunch of different
devices it could be on a phone it could
be on nice studio speakers like this it
could be coming through a tv you can't
actually guarantee that they're gonna be
playing it through one particular sound
source so you have to make it safe and
those safe levels are generally as
follows the most important factor uh
you'll have your dialogue generally
between negative five and negative ten
decibels allowing just a little bit of
headroom for louder sound effects as far
as the sound effects themselves are
concerned you can go from zero down to
around i'd say about negative 18
decibels anything below negative 18
isn't probably going to be heard on a
like a mobile device or a tablet very
very well same goes for music the main
thing with this though is you have to
realize that speakers are low quality
and so generally the dynamic range of
your sound sources and your audio cannot
be that high when compared to a
theatrical piece or something seen on tv
so there you go numbers
getting organized while working on your
audio it's very very good practice to
keep your tracks organized before you go
into mixing and that's everything from
making sure you have your music and your
dialogue and your sound effects and your
ambient stuff all grouped together that
way when you need to start mixing your
stuff later on everything is there in
the same tracks you don't have a gunshot
in your wind track and your wind track
and your dialogue track basically it's
organized and you're not confused when
you start mixing it not to mention if
anybody else ever works with you
it's way easier for somebody else to
actually work with you if you're
organized chances are there's gonna be a
project here and there you'll come back
to it a few months later and if it's not
organized you're gonna be lost now that
your sounds are all together
and organized you're ready to start
creating the next stage in mixing which
is sub mixes
some mixes now are those select portions
of your final mix this often comes in
the form of grouping the similar sounds
such as dialogue from one person or
fully from you know a character walking
essentially allowing you to mix the
entirety of that specific type of sound
without affecting everything else when
creating the sub mix level the
individual eclipse volumes so they're
all at the same volume all the gunshots
are at the same volume for the gunshot
submix all the dialogue is at the same
volume for the dialogue submix and now
that you have your sub mix
it's way easier to apply levels and
filters need a little reverb on those
gunshots sam yep one filter will cover
them all exactly boom
if you need an equalizer to make your
foley sound like it's part of the same
scene or with a different microphone
again one filter on that entire submix
since you've organized them it's kind of
the same thing as doing your first
correction pass where you match the
exposure between all your clips and then
when you go in to do like a beauty grade
you can just apply it once and it goes
across everything correctly because
everything's been balanced first you
also might find that you'll need to make
sub mixes on a per scene level in case
your scenes take place in different
locations and will require different
levels slash filters
for each individual scene instead of for
the entire piece overall finally after
you've mixed and placed all your sub
mixes you're going to want to balance
and master all of them in relation to
each other to ensure that every mix
sounds and feels as though it is part of
one scene you'll have to be very careful
with which ones are getting the most
attention this is where the personal
intuition comes into play if one is too
overpowering consider lowering the
volume to balance it out with the rest
so once you're all done all those sub
mixes are there together you might find
upon exporting them that maybe it's a
little too quiet or maybe it's a little
too loud but that's okay because you can
just go right back in and still maintain
that dynamic range that you've mixed
everything with so now after a little
trial and error at that point you've got
a perfect mix hooray and you're done yep
remember balance and clarity are king
they are the monarch anyways guys thanks
for watching i hope you learned
something here just like when you color
grade and you get your exposure right so
you can see everything same thing with
levels you're gonna get it right so you
can hear everything exactly and you're
gonna make it relative to each other and
you're gonna get things the right
attention you can bring them in and out
and you're opening up your hand control
interface and like
[Music]
you